i find it really concerning sometimes
how many anime series have this one
character that objectively is an
absolute piece of garbage as a human
being and yet somehow ends up as one of
my favorite characters can anyone relate
that's exactly how i felt the moment
when toji entered dagon's domain through
the opening everyone had just hoped to
escape from well let me also tell you
the moment that my opinion of toji for
shigoro was completely flipped on its
head in front of you is the destroyed
city of shibuya the air thick with death
fear and chaos sucuna's presence is
piercing the air and yet here in this
small side alley somewhere on the
battlefield cramped between two
buildings a father and son stand in
front of each other without even knowing
who the other is megumi not remembering
the father that abandoned him as a child
now fully focused on getting away from
the monster that just easily took out
one of the special grades without so
much as an inch of cursed energy on the
other hand toji a mindless beast on a
killing spree who despite all the
powerful people on the battlefield has
chosen megumi as his strongest opponents
having just barely missed megomi's heart
he prepares for another deadly jab but
suddenly a memory pierces his mind a
memory of how he sold his only son to
the family he hated so much and in the
next moment despite the cursed technique
that's controlling him he takes control
again and ends his own life a second
time with a smile on his face
and i had tears in my eyes tears because
of the emotions but also tears of joy
for how criminally well-written this man
is at this point i had finally
understood who toji fushigoro truly is
as a character
[Music]
is and always has been a very strong
contender in the categories shittiest
chonin fathers and characters that are
already dead but somehow feel more
exciting than some of those that are
still alive the core philosophy that
akutami gives toji is basically not
giving a [ __ ] we're being told that toji
doesn't care about anything or anyone he
doesn't care about his family going his
own way and doing his own thing he goes
through weapons at an alarming rate no
matter if it's a cheap gun or a
priceless cursed weapon
when you think about it whenever you see
toji you never see him using the same
tool twice just switching to a new one
whenever he needs to he doesn't care
about his son and even about his own
life readily prepared to throw it away
just to make a point when i first read
the hidden inventory arc not in my
wildest dreams did i expect that this
sketchy looking guy that is supposed to
be megomi's death i mean that would be
one of the most influential powerful and
deep characters of the story it didn't
take long however for toji to get my
full attention when he's revealed as the
mastermind behind the attack on riko a
girl meant to fuse with the immortal
source rattangan so he could remain
human and not turn into whatever he's
now curse i guess fully aware that rico
is with gojo and ghetto the two most
powerful sorceress in the country right
now who are in charge of protecting the
girl until the ritual he cleverly keeps
throwing diversions at them from behind
the scenes he patiently waits until gojo
is so tired from constantly being on
guard with his six ice technique so he
can launch a surprise attack on all of
them and even though gojo was of course
already an absolute favorite of mine at
this point toji's fighting style and his
underdog status made it really hard not
to be impressed by him as he manages to
take out all three of his targets
apparently even killing gojo and despite
of how much of a dick he was abandoning
his son to drink gamble and fight the
only thing i thought was that this guy
is purely badass at first glance the
fight between gojo and toji may seem
like that of two powerful maniacs going
at it but it's actually based on chinese
mythology the godly buddha versus the
chaotic monkey king gojo who literally
quotes the buddha himself after
surviving his stabbing has reached some
sort of enlightenment now fully aware of
the true nature of cursed energy and
basically from this moment onward is
pretty much unstoppable he sees
everything and is one with the world
able to manipulate space itself his
domain expansion literally forces the
universe's truth onto you once you're
caught in it
and as he puts it himself coming back
from certain death he's practically
reborn in the infinite cycle of
reincarnation told you meanwhile
represents sun wu kong who rebelled
against the gods i'm sorry for the
pronunciation toji literally likes to
call himself a monkey for not having
cursed energy basically making fun of
ghetto before he even goes mad and just
like the monkey king is exiled from the
heavenly order of the four clans in this
case later on we see him fully mastering
playful clout just as sun wukong was
known for using a staff and flying on
top of a cloud ultimately just like in
the journey to the west the buddha
himself has to put an end to this
rebellion just like gojo is the only one
who could have ever stopped toji yoshi
and when gorju launched his new attack
hollow purple and i turned the page my
entire perspective on tolji completely
changed but first that break okay real
quick i want to talk about skillshare
the sponsor of today's video thank you
skillshare for sponsoring this video
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers thousands of
classes for all skill levels in tons of
creative and practical disciplines like
filmmaking cooking and art i actually
use guild chair a ton to upgrade my
skills here on youtube to make better
videos for you but i also use it for a
lot of personal stuff as well for
example i'm currently watching this
course on fingerpicking by chris marin
if you also want to start exploring your
creativity today the first 1000 of you
foxes to click the link in the
description will get a one month free
trial of skillshare premium okay so i
turned the page and two things happened
when a surprisingly calm tolji is
standing there with a big hole in the
side of his body firstly i finally
understood that i had been a bit of an
idiot seeing toji has some sort of
underdog fighting his way to the top
that's not what makes him so relatable
in fact just like gojo torchi had been
born with one of the strongest powers in
the jude's world right from the start
heavenly restriction that has turned out
to be an inherited technique of the
saiyan family is only able to reach its
true potential when the amount of cursed
energy in the user is exactly
zero it made toji an absolute superhuman
monster that could not be detected but
easily overwhelm cursed techniques using
his ridiculous instincts and physical
strength alone in other words gojo had
to overcome his own limits to take this
man down
[Music]
told you had always been one of the
strongest it's just that the zain clan
defines strength in terms of cursed
energy so they were quite literally
blind to his true strength just like i
was even though maki foreshadowed it so
well and even more frustratingly how
toji then foreshadowed it for maki later
on and you know what maki losing her
remaining cursed energy and essentially
becoming the kill-bill version of toji
has been one of the wildest rides in the
story so far and that is really saying
something the second thing that happened
when toji died was that i realized how
his philosophy of not giving a damn
about anything was nothing but one big
facade when he asked gojo missing half
of his body to help his son the last
thing that he thought about before dying
akutami set the stage to make this
character way deeper than i had
anticipated until now toji was cool but
now i was really curious if toji had
loved megumi after all
how the hell did he end up like this
is pretty much the personification of
the entire story of jutsu kaisen uniting
the themes of love strength and the
dysfunctional coldness of the jew to
society he is the result of the current
toxic system even though akutami never
explicitly mentions anything about his
time with the zain clan given his
current state and what we already know
from maki's experience it doesn't take
much imagination to figure that his
childhood must probably have terribly
sucked
[Music]
on maki are basically the badass but
tragic outcome of a society that denies
love and attention to anyone deemed to
be weak in their eyes whenever i see
toji or maki act the way they do you
just know that the current system has to
be abolished which is ironic because the
next arc will be about protecting set
system and yet i strongly believe that
it'll be the job of itadori for shiguru
and kugisaki to build a world in which
someone like maki can laugh and in which
someone like toji never has to become
the emotionally crippled monster that he
is i mean look at him completely
deprived of any affection toji even more
so than maki is completely unable to
express love and care even though both
their needs as a character is clearly
having a real loving family instead they
try to fill the hole in their heart by
becoming strong they basically want to
be acknowledged by the clan that treated
them as outcasts toji who's not able to
deal with the death of megumi's mother
then decides to warp his usual self as
he calls it his loving self and abandons
his kit thinking it will be safer with
the clan that rejected him i'm sure that
plan would have worked out fantastically
now in this scene here we are made to
believe that toji doesn't even remember
his own kid's name and yet megumi the
name he gave his son literally means
blessing and so even though i didn't
know it yet this right here is a man
that struggles to drown his love and
worries for his child because he just
doesn't know how to deal with it and
realizing that really broke my heart
[Music]
and it gets even worse when you see that
megumi has pretty much inherited this
trait before starting to change and grow
together with yuji and nobody megumi is
constantly and i mean constantly
suppressing his emotions as well as his
powers believing himself to be weak
before then pulling a sudden domain
expansion or then summoning mahuragan
despite his father's love for him he had
to grow out with no idea of what a
family was except for stepsister with
the same sense of isolation and distance
from his family that toji did fully
lacking the unconditional love that a
child needs from his parents in order to
grow up because toji was never even
around for megumi in the first place and
so just by default i guess he assumes
that his father either didn't love him
or just straight out forgot about him
and i think that's why knowing that toji
actually had cared for him all along
makes his character so bitter
bittersweet it's only in toji's very
last moment his second chance at dying a
good death as itadori would put it that
he accepts that it was megumi who was
his true purpose in life all along not
revenge or money or power
just family and someone to care for the
exact moral message of jude sukaisen the
only thing togi is regretting before he
dies from gojo's attack all those years
ago is not that he wasn't strong enough
he doesn't even regret becoming a
criminal or rebelling against the also
mighty jude's worlds no what he regrets
is that he threw away his family in the
process and now he has the chance to
finally see that his son grew up just
fine well more or less i guess
and that maegomi is starting to walk his
own path and so it took me that toji
pretty much dies the very way that yuji
wants to with a smile on his face and
surrounded by the people he loves which
makes toji someone who's not only
incredibly powerful and badass for
wreaking havoc in the jewish world but
who deep deep
very deep down was a loving father who
never had the chance to express it until
he got one last chance and that's why a
human piece of garbage like tolji is one
of my favorite characters
you should watch megumi's video here
next